DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
DONALD TRUMP NICKED THE IRAN
DEAL WHICH HE SAID HE WOULD DO
ALL ALONG.
>> I AM ANNOUNCING TODAY THAT
THE UNITED STATES WILL WITHDRAW
FROM THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
WE WILL BE INSTITUTING THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS.
ANY NATION THAT HELPS IRAN AND
ITS QUEST FOR NUCLEAR WEAPONS
COULD ALSO BE STRONGLY
SANCTIONED BY THE UNITED STATES.
AMERICA WILL NOT BE HELD HOSTAGE
TO NUCLEAR BLACKMAIL.
TODAY'S ACTION SENDS A CRITICAL
MESSAGE.
THE UNITED STATES NO LONGER
MAKES EMPTY THREATS.
WHEN I MAKE PROMISES, I KEEP
THEM.
>> Greg: BEFORE THAT,
APPARENTLY JOHN KERRY SPOKE TO
IRANIAN LEADERS ABOUT SAVING THE
DEAL.
I DON'T BLAME THE GUY.
KERRY'S LEGACY IS UNRAVELING
FASTER THAN A MUMMY ON A
MERRY-GO-ROUND.
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE IRAN DEAL
WAS LEGACY, IT WASN'T SECURITY.
BEFORE THIS DEAL, IRAN WAS ON
THE ROPES.
THE ECONOMY WAS HEADED INTO
NORTH KOREAN TERRITORY AND IT
WAS ABOUT AS STABLE AS
JOHN KERRY ON A SKATEBOARD.
THEN WE THREW THEM A LIFELINE.
STUPID.
WE WENT TO NEGOTIATE WITH
APOCALYPTIC THEOCRAT'S AND WE
SENT THIS GUY.
DO JAMES TAYLOR STROM SOME
MUSIC?
THE IRAN DEAL, THE NEW GUY,
TRUMP, TORE IT DOWN.
DOES THIS MEAN WAR?
IF YOU THINK THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT HARBORS A GRUDGE
AGAINST IRAN, YOU'D BE WRONG.
HE SEEMS WILLING TO TALK TO JUST
ABOUT ANYONE.
THE ONLY THING HE HATES HIS DUMB
DEALS.
HE WOULD RATHER START, THIS IS
HIS VERSION OF A RESET WITH
LEVERAGE.
>> IRAN'S LEADERS WILL NATURALLY
SAY THAT THEY REFUSED TO
NEGOTIATE A NEW DEAL.
THEY REFUSE, AND THAT'S FINE.
I WOULD PROBABLY SAY THE SAME
THING IF I WAS IN THEIR POSITION
THING IF I WAS IN THEIR POSITIO
POSITION.
BUT THE FACT IS THEY ARE GOING
TO WANT TO MAKE A NEW AND
LASTING DEAL.
ONE THAT BENEFITS ALL OF IRAN
AND THE IRANIAN PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY DO, I AM READY,
WILLING, AND ABLE.
GREAT THINGS CAN HAPPEN FOR
IRAN COMMAND GREAT THINGS CAN
HAPPEN FOR THE PEACE AND
STABILITY THAT WE ALL WANT IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> Greg: THAT'S NICE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU IN A PANIC,
REMEMBER THAT YOU FELT THAT WAY
ABOUT NORTH KOREA TOO.
AS TRUMP DEALS WITH THE WORST ON
THE PLANET, HE SCRATCHES OFF
ISIS AND NORTH KOREA, IRAN SEEMS
NEXT.
IT'S A SKILL SET THAT HISTORY
WILL BE KINDER TO THAN
JOHN KERRY.